>> Sean: SO THIS WEEK WE SAW
THE HATE TRUMP DESTROY TRUMP
MAIN STREET MEDIA BLATANTLY
ROOTING FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO WIN
IN FOUR DAYS.
IN CASE YOU MISSED IT, HERE ARE
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES.
>> YOU WANT A SLIGHT CHECK ON
THIS MAN, AND HIS UNRELENTING
RACE TO THE FINISH HERE TO MAKE
SURE HE CAN CONTINUE DESTROYING
THE COUNTRY.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO VOTE ALL D.
>> UNTIL YOU CAN STAND UP TO
THIS KIND OF HATEMONGERING BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP, REPUBLICANS ARE
IMITATING IT.
>> I KNOW I HAVEN'T STOPPED
PRAYING SINCE YOU WERE ELECTED.
DEAR GOD, WHEN WILL THIS END?
THE ONE HERE NOW, SARAH SANDERS
IS WITH US.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THIS WENT FROM NONSTOP HATE
ALMOST FROM THE DAY THE     MELN
ALMOST FROM THE DAY THE     MELE
ALMOST FROM THE DAY THE     MELA
ALMOST FROM THE DAY THE     MELD
THE PRESIDENT CAME DOWN THE
ESCALATOR, TO -- JUST NEVER
ENDING.
BLAMING THE PRESIDENT FOR THE
SYNAGOGUE SHOOTING AND YET, THE
GUY THAT SHOT UP THE SYNAGOGUE
AND COMMITTED THAT ACT OF
TERROR, THAT ANTI-SEMITIC
ACTIVATED TRUMP FOR HIS STRONG
SUPPORT OF ISRAEL.
THAT'S HOW BAD IT'S GOTTEN.
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING.
I'M JUST GLAD TO KNOW THERE IS
NO BIAS IN THE MEDIA.
ALL THE CLIPS YOU JUST SHOW TO
COME UP THEY CONSTANTLY TALK
ABOUT HOW THEY ARE FAIR IN THEIR
REPORTING, BUT WHAT YOU JUST
GAVE US WAS A GLIMPSE INTO EVERY
DAY WITH MANY IN THE MEDIA.
ONE OF THE SADDEST TRUTHS IS
THAT THEY WANT TO BLAME THE
PRESIDENT FOR EVERY SINGLE
PROBLEM IN THE WORLD BUT REFUSED
TO GIVE HIM ANY CREDIT FOR ALL
OF THE SUCCESS THAT HE HAS HAD.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS AND I
THINK YOU JUST SAW A GREAT CASE
AND THE SAD TRUTH OF WHAT WE
DEAL WITH UNFORTUNATELY EVERY
DAY.
>> YOU WATCH FAKE NEWS CNN AND
THEY DESERVE EVERY CRITICISM
THEY GET.
IT'S ALMOST EVERY SECOND, EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY
THAT THIS IS ALL THAT THEY DO,
DEMONIZE THE PRESIDENT.
AND IT HAS GONE BEYOND WHAT WE
GET EVERY TWO AND FOUR YEARS.
RACIST, SEXIST, HOMOPHOBIC,
DIRTY AIR, KILL CHILDREN ENTER
GRANNY OVER THE CLIFF.
NOW IT'S RESPONSIBLE FOR
TERRORISM OR SOME NOT THAT SENDS
BOMBS TO INNOCENT PEOPLE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS SO
STARTLING THAT CAME OUT JUST
TODAY WAS 60% OF THE COUNTRY
FEELS LIKE THE MEDIA IS DIVIDING
THE COUNTRY AND ONLY 17% THINKS
THEY ACTUALLY DO ANYTHING TO
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER.
YET, THEY CONTINUE TO TRY TO
PLACE THE BLAME ON THE
PRESIDENT.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS.
WE SAW CNN, THE FIRST THING THEY
DID AFTER THE SUSPICIOUS
PACKAGES WERE MAILED, IT WASN'T
TO CONDEMN THE INDIVIDUAL, BUT
IT WAS TO GO AFTER THE
PRESIDENT.
THE FIRST THING THE PRESIDENT
DID WAS TO CONDEMN THE
INDIVIDUAL, GO AFTER THAT
PERSON.
AT SOME POINT THE MEDIA HAS TO
PUT RESPONSIBILITY ON PEOPLE
CARRYING OUT THESE HEINOUS ACTS
AND DOING DESPICABLE THINGS.
YET THEY CONTINUE TO WANT TO PUT
EVERY SINGLE BAD THING ON THE
WORLD ON THE PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: IT WAS FUNNY TO GET
LECTURED BY JEFF ZUCKER, AND I
WAS THINKING, WATCH THY OWN
NETWORK.
BUT EITHER WAY WITH THE PUBLIC
60 PLUS PERCENT SEEING THE MEDIA
IS THAT WAY, I DON'T THINK IT
MEANS AS MUCH.
NOW THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ON
THE ROAD AND HAS DONE 11 STOPS
IN LESS THAN A WEEK AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS GONE ALL IN ON THE
CAMPAIGN, AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THE POLLS ANYMORE BECAUSE I
THINK THERE IS AN INCALCULABLE
BASE OF TRUMP VOTERS THAT WILL
NEVER TALK TO THE MEDIA, OR ANY
POLLSTER.
THEY ARE GOING TO GO CLICK AND
NOT ANSWER, OR LIE TO THEM.
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND YOU CAN SEE
THAT AT EVERY ONE OF THE EVENTS
OF THE PRESIDENT HAS HOSTED NOT
JUST OVER THE NEXT COMING DAYS
BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST MONTH.
IN SOME PRESS OF THE TYPES OF
CROWDS AND THE PEOPLE AND THE
ENTHUSIASM THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
TURNING OUT PARTICULARLY WHEN HE
IS NOT ON THE BALLOT.
WE HAD A GREAT MOMENTUM GOING
INTO TUESDAY, AND IT'S
INCREDIBLE BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
HAS HAD TWO YEARS AND PEOPLE
HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION.
DO THEY CONTINUE TO GO TO DOWN
THE ROAD THEY ARE ON, ONE OF THE
BEST ECONOMIES THAT WE HAVE SEEN
IN YEARS IF NOT IN HISTORY HAS
HAPPENED UNDER THIS PRESIDENT
AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE TAX
CUTS AND BECAUSE OF HIM GETTING
RID OF THE JOB KILLING
REGULATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN A
BURDEN ON BUSINESSES,
PARTICULARLY SMALL BUSINESSES
OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
>> Sean: WE HAVE 250,000 JOBS,
AND NORMALLY WHEN YOU HAVE A
HURRICANE IT IMPACTS JOB
CREATION.
WE HAD UNEMPLOYMENT AT A 49 YEAR
LOW, AND WE HAVE IT LITERALLY
8 MILLION AMERICANS OFF OF FOOD
STAMPS AND OUT OF POVERTY AT
THAT TIME.
LITERALLY THE BEST TWO YEARS
ECONOMICALLY THAT WE HAVE EVER
HAD.
YET I DON'T THINK WE HAVE EVER
WATCHED ANYONE IN THE BIG THREE
NETWORKS, "NEW YORK TIMES" OR
"WASHINGTON POST" ," EVER TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS REALLY AN ECONOMIC
MIRACLE.
>> Sarah: THEY ALL SAID IT
COULD NOT BE DONE AND FRANKLY
THE SAD PIECE IS, I THINK A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA WANT TO
SEE THE PRESIDENT FAIL AND IT
DRIVES THEM ABSOLUTELY CRAZY
THAT HE CONTINUES TO SUCCEED
WEEK AFTER WEEK, MONTH AFTER
MONTH, AND DELIVER ON THINGS
THEY SAID WERE NOT POSSIBLE
UNDER ANY PRESIDENT, MUCH LESS
THIS PRESIDENT, AND HE CONTINUES
TO SURPRISE THEM ALL AND I THINK
HE WILL DO THAT AGAIN ON
TUESDAY.
>> WHATEVER THEY PAY YOU, IT'S
NOT NEARLY ENOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU DO THIS
JOB.
>> I LOVE THE COUNTRY AND I'M
PROUD TO SERVE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK WE HAVE A GREAT STORY TO